ever wondered how Catherine O'Hara
managed to make us laugh by sobbing
uncontrollably how could she make crying
sound so funny
if you've seen Disney and Pixar's
Elemental then we have a feeling the
answer is yes this voice cast defied The
Elements to bring these characters to
life and we're going behind the scenes
to see just how they did it while it may
seem strange to a lot of us not all
animated films allow their cast to work
together in studio it's often a pretty
solitary process even though it's hard
to imagine when we're watching the final
product for Elemental however cast
members were able to work with each
other in real time on some scenes and as
far as we're concerned this shows
through in their work you're so hot
excuse me no I mean like you're smoking
it's easy to see by how these characters
bounce off each other that the cast
members definitely formed bonds with one
another while filming and with a cast
like this one we can imagine just how
much fun this process must have been we
all know legendary comedy actor
Catherine O'Hara from something
different many of us know her as the
iconic Moira Rose in the Beloved sitcom
screen week While others know her
as Kate McAllister AKA Kevin's mom in
Home Alone Delilah Dietz in Beetlejuice
or the voice of Sally in The Nightmare
Before Christmas among many
many others yet younger audiences are
going to know her as the voice of Brooke
ripple from Elemental as she has with so
many characters over the years O'Hara
brought humor and charm to Brooke and in
her opinion it was really fun to record
and O'Hara wasn't the only member of the
cast who was happy that she was part of
it he's one of the best actors
in the world Mamadou ache clearly has
love for his Elemental on-screen mom but
fans have just as much love for his
portrayal of Wade Ripple and how he got
this now iconic role is quite an
interesting story Elementals director
Peterson sought ache out to play Wade
Ripple specifically for his crying in
the miniseries oh Jerome no
what Wade Ripple has to do plenty of
over-the-top crying in Elemental so it's
easy to see why son wanted an actor who
he knew could do the job but besides his
goofy crying practice there was another
way that Ace was uniquely qualified for
the role and this gave Elemental and his
character Wade a special place in oche's
heart I became a citizen over making
this movie his family moved to the U.S
when he was just six months old from
Mauritania you may remember from his
role as Ramsay Cole and Jurassic world
Dominion well according to him when the
covid-19 pandemic shut down immigration
offices it almost made it impossible for
him to appear in a film that was a huge
step in his career it's easy to see then
why achieving this Monumental goal while
filming Elemental gave him a major
connection to the movie but it also
strengthened his connection with his
family thinking about all the journey
that my family like took just to get
here it's been extremely moving and his
parents certainly related to the film
too my parents they saw the movie of the
premiere and my dad had seen it like
twice since it's clear that this film
had a huge impact on Ace and his family
everything about this movie is something
that is near and dear to my heart
personally and to think that this
perfect casting all happened because
he's such a great crier
Mamadou wasn't the only member of
Elementals cast who got their role
thanks to one part they played in the
past Leah Lewis plays Amber Lumen her
performance as Ellie Chu in the half of
it helped to get her the role in
Elemental because according to Peter he
could hear how vulnerable she was in her
voice clearly Peter can pick out a voice
he loves in any role but Lewis has voice
acted before she's Batgirl in the bat
Wheels Cartoon Network series yep landed
me a big one still while Lewis is no
stranger to watching as her voice makes
an animated character whole that doesn't
mean that she wasn't Amazed by watching
a Pixar movie come to life to be able to
see all the different characters pop out
at you and really come to life oh my
goodness and while we can't imagine her
playing any other character in the movie
as well as she played Ember according to
the BuzzFeed quiz Lewis is actually more
of a Claude go figure she's still team
member though I just related a lot to
the character Ember she is this little
Fireball but she's also a character that
is incredibly loyal to her family one
other Elemental voice actor who is
clearly perfectly paired with their
character that would be Wendy McLendon
Covey and her character Gail cumulus yep
there is no doubt in Wendy's mind that
she and Gail were made for each other
after seeing my character we are total
twins
and while we don't see the physical
resemblance between this legendary
comedic actor and this pink Cloud that
she sees there's no question why she was
cast in this role in her many TV series
and films like the Goldbergs and
bridesmaids Wendy always knows exactly
how to deliver a joke and she proves it
yet again as Gail
still as far as she's concerned this
movie was more than just funny this will
just hit you right in the feels now
Wendy may think that she and her
character are total twins but Sheila Omi
has her own reason for relating to her
character Omi plays Cinder Lumen who
immigrates to element City with her
family Omni says that she can relate
because she is a child of immigrants
herself taking on this role reminded her
of what it was like to grow up in the
environment she did no matter how tough
things got we were always grateful to be
alive and we laughed a lot it's clear
that Peter had this in mind when he cast
the movie I think putting your heart
into the story is a big ingredient to
what makes a Pixar film work Cinder
lumen's husband Bernie Lumen was played
by Ronnie Del Carmen and he's got ties
to his character that are similar to
that of his on-screen wife being an
immigrant being a father being a son
myself yep del Carmen and Bernie Lumen
are two fiery Peas in a Pod Plus Bernie
runs a shop called fireplace and Del
Carmen is no stranger to running things
either while he's voice acted before
he's more frequently working behind the
scenes he co-directed and wrote inside
out as well as being a storyboard artist
story supervisor and animator on many
other Classics one cast member without
quite as many credits is an animated
movie newcomer innocent akakati still
while he's new to the big screen he's
actually been acting since he was only
three years old you may have seen him in
Little America and good trouble he
managed to take on not one but two roles
in Elemental playing twins Marco and
Polo Ripple as for Marco and Polo
Ripple's dad Alan Ripple he's played by
Matthew Yang King while you may not
recognize Matthew's face you probably
know his voice from somewhere he's
played many high-profile voice acting
roles in TV movies and video games I
think you do recognize is his face from
somewhere though Pop's diner perhaps he
played Marty mantle in Riverdale another
cast member whose face you may have
recognized and voice you definitely
recognized the honor goes to Fern
grouchwood's voice actor Joe para who
Joe para is a comedian who's appeared in
plenty of animated series as well as his
own series Joe para talks with you Pera
is known for his voice and comical old
man demeanor which definitely makes him
fit his character to a t Fern
grouchwood's voice actor has a long
history but as for clods not so much
Claude is played by up-and-comer Mason
wertheimer and this movie is actually
his first ever credited role as well as
his first feature film still you may
recognize his voice from the podcast
past my bedtime can you believe the way
these voice actors related to their
characters and made them feel real which
one was your favorite let's talk about
it in the comments and for plenty more
videos like this one be sure to like And
subscribe to the things